[Musique]
bonsoir vous retrouver pour ce nouveau
7,8 les invités ont pas ce titre parole
à jean yves henry responsable yvelines
walkom france et sylvie vice gruss et
d'amnesty international yvelines à
l'occasion de la journée mondiale des
réfugiés une soirée des changes sur la
réalité de la situation des réfugiés en
france est organisé ce soir montigny le
bretonneux
nous ferons un point sur l'événement et
puis nous recevons aussi dans cette
émission civile pochon président du club
de football de montigny le bretonneux
samedi 17 ans le club a reçu le label de
foot jeunes pour la saison 2015 2016
à l'occasion de la journée mondiale des
réfugiés une soirée des changes sur la
réalité de la situation des réfugiés en
france est organisé à voisins le
bretonneux pour en discuter ce soir nous
recevons jean yves henry responsable
yvelines welcome france et sylvie vice
gruss d'amnesty international yveline
bonsoir bonsoir
au delà cela soirée de la journée
mondiale des réfugiés pourquoi avoir mis
en place cette cet événement je reprends
le titre c'est parce que justement on à
l'accueil des réfugiés étaient au coeur
de notre action que ce soit sylvie ou
moins l'actualité ils nagent alité du
fait de cette journée mondiale
on essaye de
d'animer un débat une fois par an on
peut être mais d'animer le débat en
ayant des actions sur le terrain est une
des actions que l'on mène avec welcome
c'est justement l'accueil chaleureux et
fraternel de ces migrants pendant leurs
périodes de demandeurs d'asile dans des
familles qu'ils sont volontaires pour
accueillir pendant quatre ou cinq
semaines
ces demandeurs david alors c'est vrai
que ces derniers temps l'a reçu en tout
cas accueilli difficilement pas mal de
réfugiés en tout cas je préfère dire
migrants comment ça se passe c'est quoi
la situation actuellement la situation
effectivement en français est difficile
je reviendrai bien sûr pas sur les
chiffres mais je voulais simplement
rappelé que les
réfugié en france sont peu nombreux 86%
des réfugiés dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
sont 21 millions sont accueillis
seulement par cinq pays en voie de
développement
donc nous en europe nous en accueillons
très peu un hallali borg le liban qui
menacent le liban la turquie l'iran la
jordanie les les pays limitrophes donc
très peu de réfugiés viennent en france
parce que d'abord c'est loin les voies
d'accès à la france sont très
dangereuses il y a eu des milliers de
morts en méditerranée sur les routes
donc donc les gens ne les difficultés
pour arriver en france et donc c'est
vrai que
nous essayons effectivement on en
reparlera nous à amnesty de réfléchir
sur les possibilités d'un meilleur
accueil en france et dans pour nous
groupe français d'amnesty
mais aussi vous en reparlera un petit
peu plus tard une idée pour trouver une
solution rapidement à cette crise des
réfugiés qui est vraiment votre combat
voilà voilà et c'est une crise qui est
je veux dire très présente mais ça sera
pas la dernière
ce n'est pas la première et
vers hawaï comme vous irez au sein des
réfugiés climatiques environnement
pagnol est effectivement amnesty en
dehors d'une action très concrètes
on va le prendre en parler ensemble a
aussi des propositions pour essayer
d'éviter ces crises absolument
dramatique parce qu'il faut pas oublier
que les réfugiés sont des gens qui
fuient pour riis qui risquent leur vie
pour la sauver ce ne sont pas des ce ne
sont pas des gens qui partent comme ça
simplement en se disant on va arriver en
france on en allemagne l'eldorado - il
ya des gens qui fuient pour sauver leur
vie alors parlons-en de cet accueil
il y en a quelques-uns qui sont arrivés
dans les yvelines
comment ça s'est déroulé déjà au sein de
la population qui après des familles qui
les ont reçus alors les secours
catholique a organisé ça depuis 2014
pour réussir à mettre en place une
organisation puisque
l'important c'est de les accueillir avec
une organisation
quand on est organisée à ce moment là
les les conflit s'apaise entre les
résidents habituels et ses nouvelles
personnes qui arrivent dans leur
environnement et donc on a cherché avec
le secours catholique a peaufiné la
solution on a adopté une charte qui est
l'accueil en quelques semaines dans une
famille puis ensuite une autre famille
prend la succession de façon à ce que
l'autonomisation de nos demandeurs
d'asile puisse se faire pendant leur
parcours administratif en en connaissant
bien l'environnement français en
connaissant bien la langue parce que
l'on rame on leur impose des cours de
français en connaissant bien les amis de
des familles qui viennent les accueillir
et donc il reste en famille comme ça
pendant sept huit mois ça dépendra de la
longueur de leurs procédures ils ont une
mauvaise image où on a souvent enfin on
entend dire qu'ils auraient pu rester du
côté de chez eux ou qui crée de
nombreuses nuisances
vous qui suivez ce type de dossier
l'arrivée quelle est la réalité
alors il faut savoir que vraiment c'est
un des buts d'amnesty c'est apporter le
maximum d'informations
à nos concitoyens de façon à ce qu'ils
aient effectivement après ils puissent
réfléchir et surtout abandonné les
préjugés que l'on assure sur les
réfugiés
pour nous c'est essentiel nous sommes
très présents donc sur les communes de
notre région pour donner ces
informations
donner des chiffres donnés aussi une
image de ces gens qui correspond à la
réalité qui n'est pas quelque chose de
sûre tous les préjugés c'est vraiment le
but d'amnesty c'est effectivement de
d'aller dans ce sens qu'on puisse
réfléchir comment accueillir ces gens ce
sont des gens qui sont en grande
difficulté et qui ont besoin d'un
accueil bienveillant de tous et
généralement ça se passe très bien parce
que dès que derrière cette image très
négative on s'aperçoit que ce sont des
hommes des femmes et des enfants qu'ils
ont une histoire qui dure une culture
qu'ils ont une tradition qu'ils ont une
envie d'aller vers les autres qu'ils ont
envie de nous rencontrer que nous rendra
et bien ça se passe très très bien sûr
tous et humaniser ce contact avec avec
les avec ces gens en grande difficulté
et bien je vous remercie d'être venu sur
le plateau pour en discuter j'espère que
votre parole a été entendu hier sa fille
mais vous restez vous restez on passe à
un tout autre sujet le club de montigny
a reçu le label foot jeunes pour la
saison 2015 2016 pour en discuter ce
soir nous recevons le club le directeur
du club
excusez-moi de vous représenter les
clubs quand même aussi le président
monsieur pochon alors dites moi qu'est
ce que vous ressentez déjà d'obtenir ce
label
alors c'est une grande satisfaction
parce que
c'est pas un label galvaudé dans le sens
où si un label fédération française de
football qui n'est pas attribué à tant
de clubs que ça puisque la dernière de
mémoire je crois que huit clubs
seulement l'ont eue on parmi lesquels
des des clubs des clubs de foot qui sont
pas majeurs avec des équipes qui jouent
à des niveaux cfa tels que mantel que
versailles d'autres et c'est une vraie
satisfaction parce que c'est une
récompense du travail qui a été effectué
depuis des années c'est parce que
maintenant et c'est une récompense par
rapport à pas mal de paramètres
d'abord les infrastructures d'avoir oui
savoir les infrastructures sportives qui
sont mis à disposition et et qui nous
permette d'avoir suffisamment de
créneaux horaires pour pouvoir
satisfaire les différentes formations
d'autre part l'autre paramètre qui est
important c'est de se doter d'un de tout
un problème de tout un programme
éducatif et l'éducateur qui doivent être
diplômés lorsque pour pouvoir
transmettre l'information aux enfants et
c'est important il faut effectivement
que nos éducateurs soient formés aux
règles telles qu'elles sont fixés par la
fédération française de football relayé
par la ligue et par le district des
yvelines entre le grain d'autre part
c'est aussi un gage parce qu'il ya un
suivi très important ce sujet sur la
formation que l'on fait auprès de nos
jeunes
donc c'est à dire le savoir être savoir
faire le phaser effet puisque c'est à la
fois on a une vocation à former et
l'amusement certes parce que le football
reste un sport où il faut prendre du
plaisir et l'intérêt c'est de offrir
aussi à de jeunes éducateurs la
possibilité d'évoluer au sein de notre
club de s'intégrer dans les programmes
de formation et parce que c'est aussi un
excellent moyen de les fidéliser
la finalisation c'est important la
politique du club de montigny alain
petit pas l'image de la ville la
politique de la ville c'est vraiment le
sport pour tous c'est d'essayer de
mais la tis faire les gens de montigny
jeu les maîtres de personnes à l'écart
est vraiment l'aider à monter
exactement c était un label que vous
recherchez ou c'est plutôt dans l'idée
du club
alors c'est une démarche volontaire
d'abord parce que pour avoir ce label il
vous faire la demande
mois de la rumeur il faut remplir des
dossiers il faut respecter des critères
qui sont quand même très important
puisque l'obtention du label montrer
qu'effectivement il ya des prérequis et
c'est une image que l'on donne aussi
à beaucoup de monde ou dans beaucoup de
cas rempart du football et caetera et
donner règles et avoir un club labellisé
c'est important parce que ça montre
qu'on respecte pas mal de règles parce
qu'il n'ya pas que le sport c'est aussi
le japon mais le programme qui sont
associés à ce label tels que le
programme éducatif sa formation à red
quoi tout à fait l'intérêt c'est
vraiment c'est une récompense du travail
effectué au sein du club pour vraiment
accompagner les enfants est à la fois
dans le sport et dans le reste c'est
aussi apporter une meilleure image à ce
sport qui est des fois ternie par
certains comportements de joueurs ont
dit que oui très jeunes ils apprennent
des mauvaises choses alors qu'il ya des
clubs comme vous qui s'investissent
alors je pense que tous les clubs
investissent tous les clubs investissent
très clairement et c'est vrai que
on le football en l'occurrence montigny
c'est un club où il ya aujourd'hui sept
cent soixante licenciés qui est un club
qui est important dans nos licenciés et
effectivement il ya énormément d'equipe
donc beaucoup de jeunes
effectivement on a ce rôle éducatif
également de bon comportement de respect
d'autrui c'est vraiment les images du
football quelconque doigt les véhicules
et et quelques nous à montigny on essaye
d'aller dans cette volant on essaye
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment le basique
et au delà au delà du jeu il ya le
plaisir et le respect sont des règles
qui sont essentiels au pour le football
et pour notre club
pour finir les joueurs eux-mêmes en
apprenant qu'ils avaient eu ce label qui
et quelle est leur ressenti alors déjà
ceux qui étaient présents sur les
terrains une grande satisfaction parce
que du coup on a eu quand même pas mal
de représentant à la fois du district de
notre ville avec la présence des élus de
monsieur logis et demie chaque rennais
un responsable des sports
mais heureusement pardon à leur avis
or les maires de moi monsieur mourillon
président du district qui est venu
remettre officiellement ce label
d'autant plus qu'il a remis en même
temps le label football féminin où on a
eu en fait en même temps avec hélas
quelque part c'est important parce que
c'est un petit peu
c'est une vraie évolution parce qu'on
avait on avait le football dont on avait
le label bronze
on n'est pas sans label argent ce qui
montre qu'on a un travail qui progresse
qui continue et dans trois ans il faudra
re soumettre un dossier et j'ai bon
espoir que dans trois ans on aura le
niveau supérieur et qu'on aura pour
essayer surtout ce travail de fond à
montigny du profil bas et ben je l
espère aussi merci à vous je vous
remercie d'être venu sur ce plateau
c'est la fin de ce set 8 échos bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]